hello everyone and welcome to the moment
you've all been waiting for it is round
three of this year's Norway chess and
it's Hikaru Nakamura vs Magnus Carlsen
now uh everyone was expecting a thriller
in the classical time section but uh the
classical game ended in a very very
quick draw uh I'm gonna show it that
they actually played a very exciting
opening they played the martial attack
but
um uh they they played a well-known line
which just ends up in a draw so I'm just
gonna quickly go over the classical game
and then we are going to discuss what
happened in the Armageddon so in the
classical section we had the uh martial
attack so of course this it started off
with a real Lopez Knight F6 castles
Bishop D7 rookie one B5 Bishop to B3
Castle C3 and pawn to D5 uh Magnus opted
for the martial attack he captures on
the five Knight captures Knight captures
Knight captures Road captures and pawn
to C6 the so-called modern variation of
the martial attack we have D3 Bishop to
D6 and Rook D1 so everything that we've
seen many many times Bishop to F5 now
and winter F3 with Queen H4 now going
for Queen captures on H2 G3 defending at
Queen to H3 and Knight to D2 again all
been seen before a rook eat A8
uh and the Knight the E4 with Bishop to
G4 attacking the queen queen to G2 and
now uh we have a queen trade captures
captures and now Pawn to F5 and it seems
like uh White uh should be lost here as
the rook and E1 would hang once the once
the Knight moves but luckily they
respawn to H3 attacks the bishop Bishop
moves and now even Bishop to F4 offers a
trait of dark Square Bishop's captors
captures and now F captures an E4 we
have D captures on e4 so it seems that
uh the Knight and D5 will hang but again
all been seen before Bishop to F3 check
and this quickly concluded into a draw
so now you have to capture uh Rook
captures an F4 check G3 Rook F
characters and E4 the Rooks got traded
off and now of course you don't want to
allow Rook D2 so King F3 and now they
just repeat it rooked for checking G3
Rook D4 King F3 and a few more moves and
they've repeated uh up until move 31 and
they agreed to a draw and they pretty
much played the entire game in five
minutes yeah you know which is pretty
crazy as it's it's a classical game but
but um uh basically they're showing off
their their great Theory knowledge of
the martial attack so now we go into the
Armageddon game and the Armageddon game
features an even greater opening uh no
it's not the Evans Gambit I know uh but
it features the king's Gambit so here
Hikaru played Ponte E4 with Ponte E5 and
now Hikaru goes for it pawn to F4 he
goes for the king's Gambit and this is
where the the gloves are definitely off
this is not ending in a draw so he
captures on F4 Magnus accepts the Gambit
even though okay nowadays it's popular
to even go for the for the fall beer
counter game with Magnus uh you know
meets the a Gambit head-on Knight to F3
and pawn to G5 in the style of the great
players of the past like Paul morphiano
Founders and even Stein is played the
last played it uh but yeah I think uh
the the the the player with the most
positions of um of this exact position
would be Adolf Anderson so here Ponte H4
and now G4 attacking the Knight and now
Knight the E5 there are even some moves
where D4 can be played even Bishop C4
but that would be uh you know uh
underestimate underestimating magnets a
bit too much so Knights the E5 and now
Pawn to D6 chasing away the Knight
Knight to F6 is the most common move
here we have Pawn to D6 by Magnus uh
asking Hikaru is he may be interested in
the Knight captures on F7 even though
this looks like a move that you would
play in Blitz and bullet it has only
been played once uh by the great
attacker of the past Carlos schlechta uh
who also
um was a wheelchair Championship
Challenger he played it against Gaza
marozzi and he even got a very nice game
but as the move is objectively bad he
lost in some 45 moves but that was the
only instance where it was played uh so
of course Knight captures and G4 this is
the standard way to play this Knight to
F6 and now a knight captures an F6 with
Queen captures on F6 and now Knight the
C3 and D4 are the most common moves here
and it makes sense pretty much everyone
plays Knight to C3 instantly because the
queen is on F6 and you really want to
play Knight to D5 and attack that Queen
but uh Hikaru just plays Pawn to D3 it's
a weird move to play in in a crazy
position like the king's gamut but it's
also a new move so uh as of move eight
we have a completely new game so let's
see how Magnus deals with this novelty
Knight the C6 we have Queen to F3 uh
going after the F4 pawn and the Magnus
just defends at Bishop to H6 uh we have
Queen to F2 now not worrying about
Knight to D4 attacking the queen putting
pressure on the C2 pawn and Rook the G8
just putting pressure
uh on hikaru's King side next is Bishop
D6 and probably Castle in Queen side so
Knight to C3 Bishop to E6 in here Bishop
to D2 Hikaru uh Magnus Castle's Queen
side and Hikaru does the same we have
Queen to D4 Magnus very happy with his
position and a draw is enough for him to
win the game as this is Armageddon so he
offers a queen trade and Hikaru must
decline even though objectively uh
trading Queens is probably best that we
have Queen back the E1 and now Queen
back to E5 by Magnus we have Knight to
E2 now regarding that the D4 Square now
you might even have some ideas of King
to B1 C3 D4 and so on if you can somehow
defend the E4 pawn and now Pawn to F5 by
Magnus you might be thinking but what
about Bishop captures and A2 well you
could play it um uh but uh he
corresponds mostly to play G3 as the
bishop on H6 is undefended now capture
on F4 and you don't really care about
the A2 Pawn you you have to play like
this if you're playing for the win and I
mean you have played the king's gamut
you can play The King's Gambit and you
know be all a turtle-like so after night
the E2 Magnus plays spawned to F5 and
now Pawn to G3 with the same idea the
bishop on H6 is hanging F captures uh an
E4 with G captures on F4 attacking the
queen queen to F5 and now Knight the G3
attacking the queen and the pawn on e4
Queen to F7 now putting even more
pressure on this diagonal but uh Hikaru
doesn't care he just plays Pawn to F5
now exposing the dark Square Bishop to
an attack and also the Light Square
Bishop luckily uh the bush bandito can
be captured with check so Magnus plays
this bishop captures on D2 which check
Rook captures and now Bishop to D7
again ignoring this uh Bishop here as
the Knight captures an E4 would be very
strong so just Bishop to D7 and now he's
asking are you maybe interested in this
Pawn uh and well it can be played now
Queen capture 780 would be much scarier
so Queen a king to B1 now comes Knight
to E5 uh putting pressure on that F3
Square Knight to F3 will be winning
material so Queen to E3 by Hikaru and E
captures on D3 we have C captures on D3
not allowing the bishop to be captured
you really want your light score Bishop
to grab hold of some long diagonal with
Bishop to C6 which Magnus does attacking
The Rook here and Knight the E4 and here
uh we have King to B8 uh it's uh it's
sort of an uh unnecessary necessary move
because if you play the move that you
really want to play Queen characters on
F5 then you run into Bishop to H3 and
your king is on C8 and even though you
can't defend this for example Knight to
G4 uh let's say queen to E2 going after
the Knight and you can even play Pawn to
H5 is just very annoying to have your
all of your pieces on the same diagonal
as he cars light Square Bishop plate
zero Rook to F1 and you have to burn a
lot of time here looking for answers so
after night the E4 Magnus just moves the
king king to B8 he's not in any rush to
win this he's like I said very very
happy with a draw uh Bishop to H3 and
now Rook D to E8
uh we have rooked the C1 now putting
pressure on magnus's King side and now
Bishop to D5 Magnus again puts pressure
on that A2 pawn and because it's
Armageddon because he doesn't want to
waste time for nothing he misses an
instant win here uh do you see the
instant win here it's not an easy one to
spot feel free to pause the video and
try to find this idea uh while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh always being a
true master of tactics and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Knight captures on D3 just removing
the defender of the Knight on e4 yes it
is as simple as that uh now of course uh
everyone sees that if Rook captures
Bishop captures and E4 squares the rook
and there's no uh defending there's the
problem and probably why Magnus decided
against this is maybe he saw Rook
captures on C6 sort of Hikaru giving up
the Rook for two pieces but even this
loses the Knight to B4 attacks the rook
and also threatens Queen captors and A2
and there is no defense here you have to
defend against the uh Checkmate so Queen
captures capture Center just capturing
the rook and you are of course
completely winning here up the exchange
up upon you know another another trouble
in the world so I have to Rook the C1
Magnus misses this he plays Bishop to D5
and now Rook to E2 probably also uh
Magnus doesn't actually need to win he's
happy with the draw so maybe that's why
he's not looking for a for you know for
the killing blow too much uh Bishop
captures an A2 with check King the A1
and now Bishop back to D5 and Hikaru
goes Knight to G5 that was the whole
point of giving up the pawn on A2 uh but
it doesn't work okay if Magnus plays the
queen to a weird Square then it could be
a very strong if the Knight comes to E6
with some sort of a forcing maneuver but
after Queen to D7 there is nothing here
now uh you don't even have a move like
um a D4 as everything is nicely defended
and also Checkmate is being threatened
if you play something like F6 which is
also kind of the idea the Knight on G5
uh prepares F6 F7 but here if you play
F6 just Queen T4 check and you run into
one of the oldest checkmates in the book
as the queen is covering C2 you just
have Bishop to eight you're checking a
one Bishop to B3 a discovery from the
queen king to B1 and queen to A2 will be
Checkmate it's a very nice mate to know
because you will always uh have it you
know you you won't have to calculate 10
moves ahead it's enough to calculate six
if you know that this Checkmate exists
so here Queen to D4 and now opening up
the the file for the rook and also
guarding that A4 Square so so the Black
Ink Queen cannot deliver check Queen to
B5 now going uh for for the a file uh
you know via different means so King the
B1 and now even Knights the C6 attacking
the queen uh Rook captures 98 with check
Rook captures and now Queen to C3 now
comes Bishop to B3 and now Queen to A4
Queen to A2 check is coming will it be
Checkmate or just a check that's up to
Hikaru of course the car will try to
avoid this he played Knight to the E4
uh at least at least this causes of the
file for the black Rook Queen to a for
threatening mate in one and now he car
plays Rook to F1 he has to allow Queen
Tate to check but Magnus doesn't rush it
he plays Knight to D4 brings another
piece into the attack now even more
squares are being covered um in front of
the white king uh Bishop to G4 and now
just Bishop the C2 with check D5 is also
winning I mean pretty much any move is
winning here uh Magnus opts for Bishop
to C2 check King to C1 and now Queen the
A1 with check with King the D2 only move
for White Queen captures an F1 and now
uh the problem is okay now Queen
captures on D4 is possible and it is
what Hikaru played but it is not enough
Bishop captures and D3 and there is
nothing you can do if you capture the
bishop for example Queen captures just
Queen to F4 with check and once the king
moves you will play Rook captures on e4
and you're up the exchange you're up too
much material the white king is on the
run there is no playing this so after
Bishop captures on D3 He tried one last
the idea Knight to F6 but um to no avail
Magnus just played Rook to E2 with check
and he was in this position on move 40
that Hikaru Nakamura resigned in the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here yeah you either get checkmated or
you accept the the gift on D3 King
captures now comes Queen to D1 with
check and it doesn't matter what you do
king to C4 or queen to C3
uh all runs into the pretty much the
same idea I will go Queen day for with
check attack the king once the King goes
back let's say King to D3 now Queen to
C2 is Checkmate but pretty much any
other Square you go to either loses the
queen or you know you you just get
checkmated or both uh so yeah very
nicely done by Magnus uh Hikaru did play
you know okay he allowed Magnus no one
allows magnets to go for the martial
attack he allowed that he showed that
you know he has nothing to fear for
Magnus uh with the white pieces in the
Marshall uh he went for a quick draw it
was sort of a gambity thing not not just
the opening of choice but also the the
entire strategy and then went for an
even greater Gambit uh okay first the
allowed Magnus the the Marshall attack
but then he went for the king's Gambit
which is you know the crown of chess
openings basically when you play the
king's Gambit you know that you are a
true gentleman and that you know
everyone in the world salutes you you
know if they're somewhere in a bar or a
library they will salute you uh you know
for at least a week so yeah too bad for
Hikaru didn't work for him but he car
Magnus also showed that he knows the
theory of of King's Gambit quite well
and that it will not be that easy to
challenge him even in a lower time
control such as um Armageddon but yeah
you have to win you have to try
something so King's Gambit was
definitely the way to go uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
the first game that we are covering from
round three as it is the first one that
finished so there we have it I would
like to thank uh buntyang Refuge
reptiles YouTube Miho sakaria and
Brandon fukuda for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful tournament until it finishes
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day